so darvish set to work looking for his
eighth consecutive win
beat trevor bauer three nothing on a
doubleheader day august 29th in
cincinnati
1-1 is lined and caught by
the new cub ildemaro vargas making
his cups debut
he got him looking 97
the reds still with an opportunity in
this first inning two on with two out
back-to-back walks after vato lined out
to the second baseman
breaking ball mustaches puts a charge
into one right center field
moose red strike first in this one three
nothing cincinnati
knocked down by vargas he has time and
he gets goodwin
trevor bauer takes the hill with a
three-nothing
lead over their division rival to cubs
1.050
o-p-s and strikes out here good start
for bauer
3-2 again fastball right down
the middle suarez gobbles it up two outs
he is out in front a lot
and that'll happen when you're right on
the plate barnard has room
and it's a one two three first for
trevor bauer
swung on and missed he struck him out
garvish has won his last
seven starts he's trying to become the
first eight
game winner this year as barnhart
strikes out
swing and a miss garbage strikes out the
side
in the second from puerto rico
honoring roberto clementi by wearing
number 21.
in that neighborhood strike three called
paint job and the payoff pitch
fastball strike three called outside
corner of beauty
third strikeout for trevor bauer
2-2 offering from bauer
boy he's got that outside corner
just painted tonight
2-2 again appeal bring him up
two strikeouts in the inning for trevor
bauer channel your anger toward the
pitch
strike three call to the outside corner
to anthony rizzo
swing and a miss and the 1-2
pitch three straight
strikeouts
would qualify barnhart strikes out
fourth scene 15
combined strikeouts we just started the
fifth inning i've been home runs in that
game so far
paul strike three yeah now the reds are
going to avoid some frustration with the
home plate umpire
swing and a miss strike three suarez old
for three with three punch outs
trevor bauer pitching a gem
nine of them i'll tell you that's such a
nasty breaking ball tonight
struck out a batter trevor bauer
filthy i mean right now trevor bauer
he's got to be standing on that
pitcher's mound thinking you know what
they cannot hit me period
i can throw whatever i want they can't
hit this stuff
not a single walk on that tally
this will be castianos one down
akiyama or out number two
[Music]
that's a base hit and it will bring the
tying run to the plate
with two outs here in the eighth inning
and it'll be ian half
and so david bell has a decision to make
here
half has struck out all three times
against bauer
and david bell is out to the mound he
has made the call to the bullpen
trevor bauer will leave and indeed
a terrific night for bauer hap the
switch hitter hitting from the left-hand
side
now the first pitch from sims is a line
drive right at mustaccus one pitch thank
you very much
14 games five saves for iglesias
first pitch right to farmer
one out one two yet again
on the ground of otto flipped to
iglesias two down
nine that's a good month for some people
popped up and this should do it
the reds shut out the cubs three nothing
to even up this three-game set at a game
of peace it's the first time the chicago
cubs
have been shut out in 2020.